- So we had mentioned Henry's
love for Patrick Mahomes,
and you know him.
- [Kay ] Oh my gosh.
- Can you do him,
can you get him in there?
Can you get a dinner maybe out of there?
Be able to help.
- I have covered him for a long time.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Going back to Texas Tech.
You're from Texas.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- I looked at your menu.
Henry, I wanna help you out.
First of all, we gotta talk ambiance.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- The way to a quarterback
and through his stomach,
is through his offensive line.
We gotta get those invites out.
Those big boys have to come over.
So you better be cooking
up a lot of that chicken.
- Are we talking Kelce?
- No, his offensive line.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Kay] But Kelce can come too,
more the merrier.
- Okay.
- Also, he puts ketchup
on everything
- On everything, that's Texan!
All right, Patrick, yes!
- So that's what you
need to do.
I'm talking on the steak,
- That's Texan.
- on the banana split.
- I will have bottles
up and down the table.
- I love how proud I am
of that moment.
- Yes!
- Yeah, and he loves Whataburger,
which you brought
- It's Texan!
- to Kansas City,
which is a Texas thing.
- Which is Texan.
- Here's what we'll do.
We'll make a video, and I'm
not gonna send this to Patrick.
We're gonna send this to Brittany Mahomes,
his lovely wife.
That's the way to do it.
- That's smart!
- Thank you.
And Kelly Clarkson
wants to come.
- What's up, Brittany?
Yeah, I was like,
"Can I get invited?
- Yes.
- I wanna come,
I saw the video.
Melissa wants to come.
- I mean, I'll come.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- [Henry] Yes.
- Yeah!
- Yes!
- I have room.
- And Winkler.
- [Kelly] "I have room."
Henry's like,
"Everyone's coming to my house." (laughs)
- And we have ketchup,
(audience applauds)
Patrick.
- We have so much ketchup.
For anything you want.
- We love ketchup!
(Kelly laughs)
(audience applauds)
- And that's how, it's done.
You're welcome, Henry.